5 | 1+2+3+4+5+6+7... = -1/12 ???
Off 1. En 1913, le grand mathématicien G.H
Hardy, alors professeur à Cambridge, reçut
une lettre d’un (n+1)-ième crack prétendant
avoir découvert des théorèmes révolutionnaires.
J’en ai reçu moi-même. C’est souvent
subtilement faux, ou moins novateur que ça
en a l’air. Mais ce que Hardy vit le stupéfia.
Off 2. L’une des équations qui le laissa
bouche bée était l’incroyable égalité
1+2+3+4+... = -1/12. N’importe quel mathématicien
digne de ce nom aurait éclaté de rire et
immédiatement jeté la lettre à la poubelle.
Et, en effet, le professeur Hill, un mathématicien
contemporain de Hardy qui reçut une lettre
similaire, a souligné la stupidité de l’auteur
de la lettre. Mais Hardy n’était pas n’importe
quel mathématicien. Plutôt que d’y voir
une absurdité source de moquerie, Hardy y
voyait un éclair de génie. Cette équation,
combinée aux nombreuses autres égalités
stupéfiantes de la lettre, le laissa sans
voix. Il écrivit : “[Ces formules] m’avaient
complètement vaincu. Je n’avais jamais
rien vu qui n’en arrive à la cheville.
Un seul coup d’oeil était suffisant pour
me convaincre qu’elles ne pouvaient avoir
été écrites que par un mathématicien de
la plus grande classe. Elles devaient être
justes car personne ne pouvait avoir eu l’imagination
de les inventer.”
Si Hardy semblait convaincu de la véracité
de l’équation 1+2+3+4+... = -1/12, c’est
que cette équation cache bel et bien quelque
chose qui semble dépasser la plupart d’entre
nous.
Cette équation étrange, vous l’avez peut-être
déjà vu ailleurs, puisque plusieurs vidéos
sur YouTube semblent la démontrer à coups
de manipulations algébriques similaires à
celles de l’épisode précédent. Plus exactement,
ces vidéos montrent que toute supersommation
linéaire, stable et régulière des entiers
était forcément égale à -1/12. Sauf que…
Sauf que ceux d’entres vous qui ont eu le
courage de regarder l’épisode Hardcore
savent que ces supersommations linéaires,
stables et régulières des entiers sont pires
que fausses. Elles sont inconsistentes.
Off 2. C’est ce qu’a prouvé Rémi Peyre
dans les commentaires d’un article de Science
Étonnante. Soit S la somme des entiers positifs.
Alors S-2S+S est égal à la somme 1+0+0+0+...,
qui est donc égal à 1. Mais S-2S+S, c’est
aussi égal à 0S, qui est égal 0. Du coup,
1=0.
Vous comprenez ce que ça veut dire ? Ça
veut dire que s’il existe une supersommation
linéaire, stable et régulière des entiers,
alors 1=0. Autrement dit, tout calcul de 1+2+3+4+...
conduit à un cataclysme mathématique ! Rémi
Peyre a prouvé en une ligne que tous les
calculs de Numberphile, MicMaths et Science
Étonnante étaient faux !
Et biiiim !
Et oui, les mathématiques sont un domaine
où tout une théorie peut être réfutée
par un raisonnement d’une ligne. Ça fait
parti, je trouve, de la beauté des mathématiques.
Et dans l’Histoire des mathématiques, c’est
arrivé. Et on en parlera… Un certain Frege
s’est fait démolir par un argument d’une
ligne de Russell…
Moi, pour ma part, j’ai eu la chance de
n’avoir jamais blogué ni fait de vidéo
sur cette “preuve” que la somme des entiers
valait -1/12 avant d’avoir lu le commentaire
de Rémi Peyre. Je serais tombé dans le panneau
comme tous les autres. J’ai vraiment eu
de la chance…
Ceci étant dit, s’il est vrai que la somme
des entiers n’a pas de supersommation linéaire,
stable et régulière, l’équation 1+2+3+4+5+...
= -1/12 semble néanmoins vraie… Et le plus
fou, c’est que la “preuve” la plus convaincante
que je connaisse de cette égalité est un
fait expérimental venu de la physique…
Off 3. En 1948, le physicien Hendrik Casimir
fit la prédiction insensée que le vide avait
de l’énergie. Et pas n’importe quelle
énergie. Casimir argua que les vibrations
stationnaires entre deux murs avaient toutes
une énergie proportionnelle à leur fréquence.
Du coup, la vibration de mode 1 avait une
énergie proportionnelle à 1. Celle de mode
2 avait une énergie proportionnelle à 2,
et ainsi de suite. Pour déterminer l’énergie
totale des vibrations, Casimir ajouta toutes
les énergies de toutes les vibrations, ce
qui le conduit à une énergie égale à 1+2+3+4+5+...
Cette somme a priori, est divergente, infinie.
Mais une énergie infinie, ça n’a pas de
sens !
Off 4. Casimir aurait sans doute dû rejeter
sa théorie. Mais, il connaissait sans doute
le travail de Ramanujan, et osa l’exploiter
pour faire ce qui est peut-être la prédiction
la plus insensée de toute l’Histoire de
la physique : il prédit que l’énergie
totale culminait à -1/12 fois l’énergie
de la vibration de mode 1, laquelle est inversement
proportionnelle à la distance entre les plaques.
En particulier, la dérivée de l’énergie,
qui correspond à une force, est une force
qui attire les plaques, et l’intensité
de cette force est exactement prédite par
le calcul déraisonnable de Casimir.
Et le plus fou, c’est qu’en 1997, cette
prédiction insensée de Casimir a été confirmée
par l’expérimentation ! C’est incroyable
! Non seulement ceci montre l’existence
d’une énergie du vide, ce qui est de l’ordre
du débilement improbable, mais ceci suggère
aussi que l’étrange égalité 1+2+3+4+...
= -1/12 a un fond de vérité. Et ça, c’est
pire que débilement improbable ! Surtout
quand on sait que l’on ne peut pas déduire
cette égalité de manipulations algébriques
!
Voilà qui pose un vrai problème. On sait
que, en un certain sens, 1+2+3+4+... = -1/12,
mais on ne sait pas pourquoi ! Le grand mathématicien
Edward Frenkel l’affirme lui-même, dans
cette vidéo
de Numberphile : “”
Enfin. Il y a tout de même au moins trois
“bonnes” raisons de penser que la somme
des entiers est -1/12. Malheureusement, ces
“bonnes” raisons sont un peu compliquées.
Donc je ne vais pas en parler ici…
En fait si ! Allez, soyons fou ! Spoiler alert.
Ça va piquer. Si vous n’avez pas un bon
niveau de lycéen, voire un niveau universitaire,
vous n’allez sans doute pas comprendre le
reste de cette vidéo. Et je m’en excuse.
Mais je vous invite quand même à essayer
de vous frotter aux quelques notions qui vont
venir, juste histoire d’être sensibilisé
à la manière de penser des mathématiciens…
Au final, bien souvent, même les mathématiciens
ne comprennent que très partiellement ce
qu’ils étudient ! Et c’est très clairement
mon cas vis-à-vis de la cause profonde de
l’équation de cette vidéo.
Off 4. Commençons par la régularisation
“par l’exponentielle” de cette série.
On peut rajouter un petit terme géométrique
à chaque terme de cette somme infinie pour
la rendre convergente. On obtient alors la
gentille somme infinie convergente 1*e^-x
+ 2*e^ + 3e^ +… Cette somme infinie
est “gentille” car on peut en calculer
la valeur exacte, même si c’est un peu
technique. Remarquons que c’est la \sum
n e^, qui est - \sum (e^)’ = - (\sum
e^)’. On reconnaît là une série
géométrique, dont on connaît la valeur,.
On obtient donc la dérivée de 1/(1-e^).
Qui est égale à - e^ / (1-e^)^2.
Pour retrouver la somme des entiers, il nous
faut maintenant prendre la limite de cela
quand x tend vers 0. Manque de bol, et comme
on aurait pu le prévoir, cette expression
tend vers l’infini quand x tend vers 0.
Et là, l’astuce de physicien, c’est d’en
regarder un développement limité. Quand
on cherche à exprimer cette expression avec
des sommes de puissances de x, on obtient
-e^ / (1-e^)^2 ≈ 1/x^2 -1/12 + o(1).
Saperlipopette, voilà le -1/12 ! Plus précisément,
à une expression divergente près, la somme
régularisée tend, lorsque x tend vers 0,
vers -1/12.
Convaincus ? Non ? Moi non plus. Pourquoi
a-t-on choisi la régularisation “par l’exponentielle”
? N’aurait-on pas obtenu quelque chose d’autre
avec une régularisation différente ? Étrangement,
non. Si on choisit une régularisation de
la forme \sum n \eta(nx), avec \eta(0) = 1
et \eta suffisamment dérivable et décroissant
suffisamment vite vers 0 à l’infini, alors
on obtient généralement un résultat similaire
: \sum n \eta(nx) \approx cte(\eta) / x^2
- 1/12 + o(1). Encore une fois, ce mystérieux
-1/12 apparaît ! Et le fait que ce résultat
ne dépende pas vraiment du choix du régularisateur
\eta suggère qu’il y a vraiment un lien
entre \sum n et -1/12...
C’est quand même mystérieusement joli
tout ça. Mais il y a peut-être plus intrigant
encore… Passons à la deuxième “bonne”
raison de penser que la somme des entiers
est -1/12.
Off 5. La deuxième “bonne” raison est
reliée au problème ouvert le plus prestigieux
des mathématiques d’aujourd’hui, à savoir
l’hypothèse de Riemann, dont El Jj a déjà
parlé dans cette excellente vidéo. En bref,
l’hypothèse de Riemann s’intéresse à
la fonction dite zeta(s) = \sum 1/n^s, où
s est un paramètre qui prend des valeurs
complexes. Cette fonction est particulièrement
intéressante, car elle est intimement reliée
à la distribution des nombres premiers. En
effet, on a \zeta(s) = \sum 1/n^s = \prod
1/(1-1/p^s). Enfin, ça, a priori, ça ne
marche que si s a une partie réelle supérieure
à 1. Toutefois, si l’on oublie la manière
dont on l’a défini, on voit que \zeta a
de très bonnes propriétés, qui nous invite
à la prolonger analytiquement sur quasiment
tout le plan complexe. On peut même prouver
que non seulement ce prolongement existe,
mais il est même unique, et est bien défini
partout sauf en s=1. De plus, on a des formules
qui permettent de relier les points où \zeta
était mal défini aux points où elle était
bien définie par la série \sum 1/n^s. Ceci
nous permet de calculer les valeurs de cette
fonction un peu partout, et l’on a par exemple
\zeta(-1)=-1/12. Mais si on l’interprète
maintenant avec la formule \zeta(s) = \sum
1/n^s, on tombe à nouveau, tout aussi mystérieusement,
sur l’intrigante égalité \sum n = -1/12…
Et ça, ça convainc pas mal de mathématiciens.
Peut-être pas que l’égalité est “vraie”,
mais au moins qu’elle cache quelque chose
de profond. Mais puisqu’il nous faut maintenant
boucler la boucle, revenons-en à Ramanujan…
Off 6. Ramanujan est parti de l’équation
d’Euler-Maclaurin, qui permet d’approximer
l’aire sous la courbe d’une fonction par
l’histogramme de la fonction et une correction
que l’on déduit des dérivées aux extrémités.
Il reste alors une petite erreur, mais Ramanujan
choisit de négliger cette erreur. Ramanujan
prit ensuite la limite de ces expressions
quand n tend vers. Sauf qu’il y a beaucoup
de choses qui divergent quand n tend vers
l’infini. Et bien, Ramanujan choisit purement
et simplement d’enlever tous les termes
qui dépendent de n, pour ne s’intéresser
qu’à ce qu’il reste quand les infinis
de l’expression sont supprimés. Ramanujan
appliqua enfin sa formule mystérieuse à
la fonction f(x) = x, et fut émerveillé
par ce qu’il obtint… Ce qu’il obtint,
c’est encore une fois l’étrange égalité
1+2+3+4+... = -1/12… Je sais que c’est
faux, mais je commence
à croire que c’est vrai...